hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be speaking
about bespoke
sourcing agreements what is a bespoke
sourcing agreement and as a deal sourcer
and by the way you should all be deal
sources if you're in property you should
be packaging and selling deals for a fee
why i think
bespoke deal sourcing is one of the most
powerful ways
to package and sell deals the easiest
and who avoids
a lot of the rubbish that comes with
deal sourcing when you do it bespoke
so if you enjoy my youtube channel
please do me a massive big favor
smash the like button also subscribe to
the youtube channel
there's nobody in the united kingdom
that's doing as many property deals as
i'm doing
that's putting out as much content
teaching and sharing openly how they're
doing it as i am so if you appreciate
that
help me out by smashing the like button
and also subscribing to the channel
so what is bespoke sourcing so before i
talk about bespoke sourcing let me tell
you about what just deal sourcing in
general is
if you already know it'll take me a
moment and then i'm gonna then i'm gonna
give you the advanced version which is
bespoke to your sourcing so deal
sourcing very simply when you package up
a deal
you find a property deal you package it
you negotiate the price
and then you find an investor and you
sell the deal onto the investor for a
finders fee typical finders fee might be
around about 3 000
pounds if you do that once a month
you don't have to have a normal job and
let me tell you something
finding a deal and selling it once a
month is much easier than working for
someone else's company
where you're doing deals doing things
and and the company's getting rich
and you're doing all the work so i would
recommend that everybody do deal
sourcing
if you're already full-time in property
and you're already making a good amount
of money
from being a property investor well
you're going to be finding properties
that aren't suitable for you or maybe
you're going to be finding properties
that you can't quite afford to buy
so what are you going to do with them
flush them down the toilet no
you're going to pass them on to an
investor and charge a fee and use that
fee to put towards your next property
investment yourself
so what is bespoke deal sourcing
one of the problems to do for deal
sources is that they'll go out there
they'll spend weeks finding a deal
they'll negotiate the deal they'll have
the offer accepted
yes but then they can't find an investor
to sell the deal to and and all their
investors are going to be
wasting time messing around so what's
the way to stop that happening
and i always teach this i say to my to
my
students on samuel 365 i say before you
find a deal find an investor
because if you find some investors and
you say what are you looking for what
kind of a
deal are you looking for they'll tell
you what they're looking for and then
you go out and find that deal for them
that's the way to do it now one of the
problems with that is people will tell
you all day long
yes i'd love to buy you know a big
mansion in london and i've got all the
money
and then you go and find it and then
they go oh actually now's not the right
time
and it's like okay oh i'd like to buy 10
hmos in manchester
you know i've got loads of money and
then you'll run around finding the deals
and you'll go to the investor and you'll
say i found a hm in manchester though
well let me just speak to my wife and
let me just do
and the time wasters so what are you
going to do to solve that problem
well you can ask them for their proof of
funds
and their photo id before you start
finding deals
of course you can make sure say to them
are you actually ready to buy great
but what i would recommend doing is
something called bespoke
deal sourcing here's how it works you
say to an investor
mr investor what are you looking to buy
and they'll say i'm looking to buy buy
refurbished refinance opportunities
in the birmingham area you'll say great
you'll speak to a few people you'll have
that conversation and then you're going
to say this you're going to say look how
about this
i'll send you over a bespoke sourcing
terms and conditions contract
and what it's going to say is it's going
to say that you're paying me a 1 000
pounds
are you serious deposit and what that
means is they'll pay you a thousand
pounds
and that thousand pounds is fully
refundable after
four weeks if you haven't found anything
suitable in that four weeks you're gonna
email them
all of the properties that you can find
for them that look suitable now it might
be that some investors say i'll buy
anything as long as it's got a 20 return
on investment
so you say all right great pay me a
thousand pounds are you serious deposit
and i'll put you on my bespoke sourcing
list so what that means is that means
that you'll have their thousand pounds
and you've got four weeks to go find
them a deal
now if you don't find them a suitable
deal after four weeks you're going to
need to refund them so that
that thousand pounds don't spend it
obviously
but here's the thing if they have shown
their proof of funds
and they've given you a thousand pounds
and you've got the skills to find a deal
if you find something good are they
going to actually buy yes because
they're serious
they're not talkers too many talkers in
this industry who
think about it i need to think about it
you know so you're getting a thousand
pound off them which shows that they're
going to be prepared to make a decision
they pay the thousand pound you find
them the deal and then you say great i
found a deal if you want to go ahead
here's the address here's all the
details there's complete trust
between you two and then you say if you
want to if you want it you're gonna have
to pay me the additional two thousand
pounds
after four weeks if you've not found
anything they can either extend the
terms and conditions contract
another four weeks or they can say can i
have my thousand pound back
but to be honest once they've paid the
thousand pound
it's your job to roll your sleeves up
and to go and find them a deal
if you've got four or five people on
this bespoke sourcing list
at a time and every time you pass
somebody a deal they pay you the
difference
and you go thank you very much and then
you replace them with somebody else or
you say
do you want me to find you another deal
you know i'd much rather have four or
five investors
that have all paid me a thousand pound
that are on my bespoke list
than have thousands of investors on my
list who are all complete time wasters
so that's what bespoke sourcing is on
samuel 365 we talk
more about this and you can have
one-on-one coaching calls and you can
connect with other people that are doing
this so i'm going to leave a link below
to the samuel 365 community
also if you want to spend a full day 12
hours with me
at the property investors crash course
then i'll leave a link as well for the
property investors crash course it's
completely free there's a one pound
booking fee to check you're a real
person but the
the the program is free i'll leave
details as well below see you at the
crash course
and i hope to see you on samuel 3652 and
that is
bespoke deal source inc guys if you
found that helpful
smash the like button drop a comment and
i look forward to seeing you at the
property investors crash course
peace out see you next time
you